This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Caroline Fraser grew up on the beautiful Mercer Island in Washington State. But despite the seemingly peaceful landscape, her memories of the area were long haunted by an inexplicable amount of death. In the 1970s, when Caroline was a teenager, the infamous serial killer Ted Bundy committed his first confirmed murders, not far from where Caroline lived. Then there was the man who lived down the street, who blew up his house with his family inside. I mean, it was just this horrific and inexplicable thing, which I think just stayed with me because I didn't understand it. Over the following years, Caroline would learn of more deaths, some by murder and suicide, others from car accidents while driving on the poorly designed Mercer Island Bridge. To Caroline, it felt as if there was a dark cloud looming above her corner of the world.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。卡罗琳·弗雷泽在华盛顿州美丽的默瑟岛长大。但尽管这里的风景看似平静，她对这片区域的记忆却长期被挥之不去的死亡阴影所笼罩。20世纪70年代，当卡罗琳还是个青少年时，臭名昭著的连环杀手特德·邦迪在离卡罗琳住所不远的地方犯下了他第一起被确凿证实的谋杀案。接着，还有住在街头的那位男子，他引爆了自己的房子，里面还装着他的家人。我的意思是，那是一件极其恐怖且难以理解的事情，我想它之所以一直留在我的记忆里，是因为我当时无法理解它。在随后的几年里，卡罗琳得知了更多的死亡事件，有些是谋杀和自杀，还有些是因为行驶在设计糟糕的默瑟岛大桥上而遭遇的车祸。对卡罗琳来说，她感觉自己这片土地的上空仿佛笼罩着一团阴云。
And in fact, there was. The cloud was coming from a giant smokestack just outside of Tacoma, Washington, and it was made up of lead, arsenic, and asbestos. The 70s and 80s were the heyday of the mining and smelting of heavy metals in America, metals like copper, lead, and zinc, which all released huge amounts of toxic fumes into the air. The same time period saw another awful trend, a massive spike in serial killing.
事实上，也确实如此。这团阴云来自华盛顿州塔科马市外的一座巨型烟囱，它由铅、砷和石棉组成。20世纪70年代和80年代是美国重金属采矿和冶炼的鼎盛时期，铜、铅、锌等金属向空气中释放出大量的有毒烟雾。同一时期还出现了另一个可怕的趋势，即连环杀人案的大幅激增。
These are two seemingly unrelated histories, but Caroline set out on a quest to see if there was some kind of connection here between environmental pollution and serial killing. She remembers seeing a specific article in a local paper that gave her this nagging feeling. And it was basically a kind of encyclopedia of all the serial killers who were associated with Seattle or the region. And there were so many. And I just thought, wow, that's really bizarre. You know, just a list that just went on and on. It just cried out for some kind of explanation. In her new book, Murderland, Crime and Bloodlust in a Time of Serial Killers,
这两段历史看似毫无关联，但卡罗琳踏上了一段探寻之旅，试图找出环境污染与连环杀人案之间是否存在某种联系。她记得曾在当地的一份报纸上看到过一篇特定的文章，这让她产生了一种挥之不去的直觉。那篇文章基本上是一部关于所有与西雅图或该地区相关的连环杀手的“百科全书”。而且数量之多令人惊叹。我当时想，哇，这真是太离奇了。你知道，那种没完没了的名单。它简直呼唤着某种解释。在她出版的新书《谋杀之地：连环杀手时代的犯罪与嗜血》中，
Caroline argues that the wave of serial killing in the 1970s and 80s might be related to the smelting industry's environmental pollution, and that all those toxic fumes in the Pacific Northwest possibly fueled a generation of serial killers. Caroline has written books about a lot of different things. Her first book was a biography of the woman who founded the Christian Science Church, and her Pulitzer Prize-winning book, Prairie Fires, was about Laura Ingalls Wilder, the author who wrote the children's book series, Little House on the Prairie. One thing that all these books, including Myrtleland, have in common, is that they're all actually about the environment.
卡罗琳提出，20世纪70年代和80年代的连环杀人浪潮可能与冶炼行业的环境污染有关，太平洋西北地区的所有这些有毒烟雾可能催生了一代连环杀手。卡罗琳写过许多不同主题的书。她的第一本著作是关于基督教科学教会创始人的传记，而她获得普利策奖的作品《草原大火》则聚焦于劳拉·英格斯·怀德，这位儿童文学系列丛书《草原上的小木屋》的作者。所有这些书（包括《谋杀之地》）都有一个共同点，那就是它们实际上都是关于环境的。
People have used the term Trojan horse, you know, that I'm using serial killers to sell an environmental story or something, which I think is maybe a little too programmatic or something. Um, these things just, they do occur to me just because I think I'm just sort of hyper aware of what has happened to the environment, what we've done to it, how we've carved it up. You know, we think that we're safe in the environments that we have created when I think that's not true at all. Murderland is a book with a rotating cast of villains. There's Asarco, the company that's operated a giant smokestacks across. the country since the late 1800s, there's the deadly Mercer Island floating bridge and the engineers behind it. And then, of course, there are the serial killers of the Pacific Northwest.
人们曾用过“特洛伊木马”这个词，你知道的，认为我是利用连环杀手来推销一个环保故事之类的，我觉得这可能有点太程式化了。嗯，这些事情的发生，只是因为我觉得自己对环境所遭受的破坏、我们对它造成的伤害以及我们如何将它瓜分，有着一种超乎寻常的敏感。你知道，我们以为在我们自己创造的环境中是安全的，但我觉得这根本不是真的。《谋杀之地》是一本有着走马灯般反派角色的书。这里有Asarco，这家自19世纪后期以来一直在全国各地运营巨型烟囱的公司；有致命的默瑟岛浮桥及其背后的工程师们；当然，还有太平洋西北地区的连环杀手们。
The book is a blend of true crime, memoir, and environmental history, all woven together. And it also features a lot of intriguing design elements. So I invited her into the studio to talk with me. So Caroline, one of the things that struck me about this book is that, you know, I think all of us our main characters of her own story, but it struck me, you know, you began to research this place that you're from. And in many ways, you discovered that it actually is kind of special. Like, it's the center of something that is different and alarming. And that difference can be attributed to design decisions made by people, like decisions about where the Asarco smelter is placed
这本书融合了真实犯罪、回忆录和环境史，交织在一起，其中还包含了许多引人入胜的设计元素。因此我邀请她来到录音室和我一起聊天。卡罗琳，这本书让我印象深刻的一点是，你知道，虽然我认为我们每个人都是自己故事的主角，但让我惊讶的是，你开始研究这个你长大的地方。在很多方面，你发现它其实挺特别的。比如，它是某种与众不同且令人警惕的事物的中心。而这种不同可以归咎于人类做出的设计决定，比如关于Asarco冶炼厂选址的决定，
and decisions about the design of the bridge and all that sort of stuff. Yeah. And so we'll get to the serial killers, I promise, if people are turning in for serial killer talk. But first, I want to talk about maps, because you seem to use maps a lot to make sense of how all these different things fit together. And in fact, your book opens with the discovery of a specific map. And this is a map that actually led you to start seeing this connection between Asarko's impact on the environment and serial killing. So tell me about this map.
以及关于桥梁设计等等诸如此类的决定。是的。所以，如果有人是冲着连环杀手的话题来的，我向你们保证，我们稍后会聊到连环杀手。但首先，我想谈谈地图，因为你似乎经常使用地图来理清所有这些不同事物是如何组合在一起的。事实上，你的书一开篇就讲到了对一张特定地图的发现。正是这张地图，引导你开始看到Asarco对环境的影响与连环杀人案之间的这种联系。那么，跟我讲讲这张地图吧。
Yes. And the Asarco map was something that really inspired this book. in a lot of ways. The map is put out by the Department of Ecology in Washington State. They published this GIS map that showed the whole plume of pollution that was caused by a smelter in Tacoma, which I relate to various incidents in the book. And that plume map is so fascinating to me and just the minute that I saw it, I just was kind of overwhelmed by. the possibilities that it presented because you can plug in your address or any address in the Seattle area, Tacoma area, and see how much pollution it may have received from the
是的。这张Asarco地图在很多方面确实是这本书的灵感来源。这张地图是由华盛顿州生态局发布的。他们发布了一张GIS地图，展示了塔科马市一家冶炼厂造成的整片污染羽流，我在书中将这片羽流与各种事件联系了起来。那张羽流地图对我来说太迷人了，就在我看到它的那一刻，我简直被它所呈现的各种可能性给震撼了，因为你可以输入你的地址或西雅图地区、塔科马地区的任何地址，看看它可能从塔科马铅冶炼厂的烟囱里接收了多少污染。
smokestack at the lead smelter in Tacoma. And so how did you first learn of the company of Sarcoe and discover this GIS map? Like, was there this, like, aha moment that led you down the path of research for this book? Yeah, there definitely was a moment, which occurred because my husband and I decided that, you know, we wanted to maybe look for some property up in the Northwest because I still have family up there. And this was around 2014. We went up there to look at some pieces of property. And one of these pieces was on Vashon Island, which is an island in Puget Sound just across from West Seattle. And one of the real estate ads said, and this is at a point where I knew nothing about the smelter, I knew nothing about any of the pollution. The real estate ad said, arsenic remediation necessary. And I read that and I thought, what the, what could possibly have caused enough arsenic on Vashon Island that it needed to be remediated? because I was familiar with Vashon, which is a beautiful kind of rural island where, you know,
那么，你是怎么第一次听说Asarco这家公司并发现这张GIS地图的呢？比如，有没有哪个“醍醐灌顶”的时刻，引领你走上了这本书的研究之路？是的，确实有过这样一个时刻，起因是我和丈夫决定，我们想在西北地区找一块地产，因为我还有家人在那边。那是大约2014年的时候。我们去那边看了一些房产。其中有一处在瓦什逊岛上，那是普吉特海湾中的一个小岛，就在西雅图西部的正对面。当时一则房地产广告上写着——当时我对这家冶炼厂一无所知，对任何污染也一无所知——那则房地产广告上写着：“需要进行砷污染修复”。我看到后心想，什么鬼，瓦什逊岛上到底怎么会有足够多的砷，以至于需要进行修复？因为我对瓦什逊很熟悉，那是一个美丽的乡村岛屿，我小时候经常去那里，因为我妈妈在那儿有个朋友，对方有一个美丽的花园，我们还在花园里吃过草莓。参观完之后，我查阅了有关砷的资料。我试图弄清楚是什么造成了这种情况。当然，我立刻找到了关于Asarco的记载，因为瓦什逊正是受烟囱排放物严重污染的地区之一，因为它就隔着水面相望。是的。
we used to go when I was a kid because my mom had a friend there who had a beautiful garden and we ate strawberries out of our garden. After this visit, I looked up the arsenic. I was trying to figure out what caused this. And, of course, immediately found references to Asarko because Vashon was one. one of the areas that was heavily slimed by the stuff that was coming out of the smokestack because it was right across the water. Yeah.
好吧。所以在《谋杀之地》中，你追溯了Asarco这家公司的兴衰。在这个时间线和地理背景的基础之上，书中还穿插了你自己的生活记忆、桥梁的兴衰，以及默瑟岛浮桥的故事。你极其详细地描述了各种连环杀手的个人历史和活动。你曾经接受过一次采访，在采访中你说你的办公室里有一个标着“连环杀手”的盒子。那么，你对连环杀手的兴趣持续多久了？比如，你觉得这一切是从哪里开始的？哦，我知道它具体是从什么时候开始的。它始于1974年7月，当时有两名女性从萨米什湖的一个海滩上失踪，萨米什湖紧邻华盛顿湖，只有几英里远。她们是特德·邦迪的两名受害者，我认为正是因为她们同时失踪，两人的失踪才清楚地表明，此前发生在西雅图及其他附近城市的这一系列零星的女性绑架案其实都是相互关联的。而且你必须意识到，当时“连环杀手”这一整体现象并没有真正成型。我的意思是，对于联邦调查局中正在从事侧写项目的那些人来说，它可能已经成型了。但对于普通公众来说，我们根本没有意识到这种事甚至是存在的。所以，
Okay. So in Murderland, you trace the rise and fall of this company, Asarko. And on top of that timeline and geography, the book weaves in and out stories from your own life and memory and the rise and fall of the Mercer Island Bridge. And you write in great detail about the personal histories and activities of various. serial killers. You once gave this interview where you said that you had a box in your office labeled serial killers. Like, how long have serial killers been an interest of yours? Like, like, where do you think that began for you? Oh, I know exactly when it began. It began, you know,
竟然有人会把女性从宿舍或街道上强行掳走，然后她们就此人间蒸发，这种想法简直极其诡异又令人恐惧。所以，我认为这就是我开始意识到这种犯罪问题，尤其是它与太平洋西北地区的联系的时刻。是的。我觉得你书的封面非常引人注目。背景是Asarco冶炼厂，前景是特德·邦迪的脸。这些图像以某种方式融合在一起，特德·邦迪的头部同时也是他身后烟囱里喷出的污染羽流。这是对你布局全书方式的一种极佳的视觉呈现，也就是将这些历史相互重叠，以指出它们之间可能存在的联系。那么，你是在什么时候开始个人察觉到连环杀手式的暴力与这种环境暴力之间存在联系的呢？我想大约是在我开始了解铅与犯罪之间的联系的时候。铅与暴力增加有关。如果你在童年时期接触过铅，那么20年后的年轻时期，你可能更容易出现少年 delinquency（青少年犯罪）、攻击性或冲动行为。当我了解到这一点，并且
in July of 1974 when two women disappeared from a beach at Lake Samish, which is right next to Lake Washington, it's only a few miles away. And they were the two victims of Ted Bundy who really, I think, because they disappeared at the same time, their disappearances made it clear that this sporadic series of abductions of women that had been taking place in Seattle and other cities nearby were all tied together. And I think you have to realize that the whole phenomenon of serial killers had not really gelled at that point. I mean, it may have gelled for people in the FBI who were working on a, you know, pro-filing program. But for the general public, we just weren't really aware that that was something that even existed. And so the
大约在同一时间了解到塔科马市存在冶炼厂时，我的脑海中亮起了几盏小灯，将以下事实联系在了一起：其中几位非常著名的连环杀手，即特德·邦迪和加里·里德韦，他们都是在塔科马地区长大的。我想，哇，这是一个有趣的巧合。我禁不住想，这背后会不会有什么原因呢？我其实并不认为自己能证明这些人之所以做出那些行为，是因为他们成长于塔科马地区。
The idea that there was somebody out there plucking women out of their dorm rooms or their, you know, off of streets and they just vanished was just profoundly strange and frightening. And so that, I think, was the moment when I became aware of the whole issue of this kind of crime, especially its connection to the Pacific Northwest. Yeah. I found the cover of your book really striking. You have this asarco smelting plant in the background and Ted Bundy's face in the foreground. And the images kind of blend into each other. And Ted Bundy's head is also the cloud of pollution coming out with the smokestack behind him. It's this great visual representation for the way you lay out the book, you know, sort of overlapping these histories onto each other to point out how they might be connected. So at what point did you personally start to see a connection between, the serial killing type of violence and the kind of environmental violence. I think it was around the time that I began to learn about the connection between lead and crime. Lead is associated with increased violence. If you're exposed to it as a child, you may, you know, 20 years later, as a young person, be more inclined. to juvenile delinquency or to aggression or to impulsivity. And when I learned about that and
但我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣、值得深入探讨的巧合。让我们再深入探讨一下这种联系。首先，正如你所说，铅与犯罪的理论，
around the same time learned about the presence of the smelter in Tacoma, these little light bulbs went off in my head connecting the fact that a couple of these very notable serial killers, namely Ted Bundy and Gary Ridgway. They both grew up in the Tacoma area. And I thought, wow, that's an interesting coincidence. I wonder if there could be any reason for that. I didn't really think that I could prove that, you know, these men did what they did because they grew up where they were in the Tacoma region.
它的核心在于这样一种观点：幼儿时期的铅暴露会导致大脑发育改变或发育受阻，这反过来又会导致一系列问题，
But I just thought it was a really interesting coincidence that was ripe for exploration. Let's explore this connection a little bit more. So, first of all, the lead crime theory, like you said,
比如缺乏冲动控制能力或攻击性增强。你书中关于连环杀人案的观点正是建立在现有的铅与犯罪理论基础之上的。比如，我知道，
it centers around this idea that lead exposure in early childhood can lead to altered or stunted brain development, which in turn can lead to a whole host of things
我还记得铅无处不在的那个年代，它存在于所有东西里，比如汽油、油漆和儿童玩具。所以我猜想，铅毒性当时也无处不在。因此我很想知道，为什么你认为太平洋西北地区在20世纪70年代和80年代会特地涌现出这样一批连环杀手。是的，好吧，所有在20世纪40年代到80年代之间长大的人，由于含铅汽油的原因，确实都比我们本应该接触到的更多的铅进行了暴露。但全国某些地区和某些城市拥有冶炼厂或其他工业工厂，它们向大气中排放了更多的铅和其他污染物。塔科马冶炼厂最臭名昭著的地方在于，
like a lack of impulse control or increased aggression. And the point your book is making about serial killing builds on this existing lead crime theory. Like, you know,
它不仅释放出惊人数量的铅颗粒物，还释放出砷。它们在本质上属于城市地区的区域内排放了数千吨这些物质。而且大量的铅和砷都降落在塔科马，降落在各个社区，尤其是北塔科马的社区以及一个名为“天际线”的社区——年轻的特德·邦迪就是在那里长大的，他住的房子不仅接收来自冶炼厂的铅，而且还紧邻16号公路这条交通繁忙的高速公路。所以他是双管齐下、全盘接收。加里·里德韦也是如此，他住在几条高速公路附近，距离西塔科机场只有东边几英里远。当然，那时候飞机、喷气式飞机使用的也是无铅燃料吗？不对，当时用的是含铅燃料。
I remember a time when lead was everywhere, it was in everything, like gasoline and paint and kids' toys. And so I imagine that lead toxicity was everywhere, too. So I'm wondering why you think the Pacific Northwest specifically had this crop of serial killers in the 70s and 80s. Yeah, well, it is true that all of us who grew up between the, you know, 1940s and the 1980s were exposed to more lead than we should have been exposed to because of leaded gas. But there were certain parts of the country and certain cities where you had smelters or other industrial plants that were emitting lots more lead into the atmosphere and other pollutants. The notorious thing about the Tacoma smelter was that
因此，我对此研究得越多，对铅的了解越多，以及它在全国某些地区和某些城市的普及程度越高，我就越对这可能暗示着什么产生兴趣。好了，既然所有这些环境因素都如此复杂，你又是如何开始厘清什么是导致问题的原因、什么不是的呢？因为，你知道，你引用了大量的研究表明，成为连环杀手的人往往经历过忽视和虐待。他们通常来自经济实力薄弱的社区。而这些地方也正是工厂经常建造的地方，因为人们没有经济实力去抱怨它们。
it was releasing extraordinary amounts of lead particulates, but it was also releasing arsenic. They're emitting, you know, thousands of tons of this stuff in essentially an urban area. And a lot of this lead and arsenic were falling on Tacoma, on neighborhoods, especially the neighborhoods of North Tacoma and this neighborhood called Skyline, which is where a young Ted Bundy is growing up in a house that is not only receiving lead from the smelter, but also it's right next to Highway 16, which is a heavily traveled highway. And so he's getting it coming and going. So is Gary Ridgeway, who lives near a couple of highways and just a couple miles east of CETAC Airport. And of course, airplanes are also, jets are also flying unleaded fuel at that time.
所以你如何开始理清这件事情的复杂性？你又是如何勾勒出你所描绘的这幅画卷的呢？是的，我认为首先你必须承认，一个人可能会遭遇各种各样的问题、缺陷或灾难，从而将他们引上那条道路。这不仅仅是铅暴露的问题，还可能存在基因因素。现在有一些特定的基因可能与攻击性增加有关。正如你所说，还有家庭暴力、家庭虐待、性虐待、头部创伤。所以，是的，导致这种情况发生的原因有很多很多。我认为吸引我的是去讲述我知道的关于Asarco的事实，了解Asarco是如何表现的，追踪他们
So the more I looked into this, more I was finding out about lead and how prevalent it was in certain parts of the country, in certain cities, the more I became interested in what that might suggest. Okay, so all these environmental factors are so complicated, how do you begin to tease apart what is causing a problem and what isn't? Because, you know, there's a ton of research that you cite that people who become serial killers often experience neglect and abuse. They often come from communities with little economic power. And those are also the places where factories are often built because people don't have the economic power to complain about them.
隐瞒自己所作所为的历史，你知道的，随着社区对他们所看到的健康影响（比如哮喘、各种呼吸道问题，宠物死亡）越来越担忧，你知道的，他们甚至无法在自己的社区里种植作物，因为它们都被砷杀死了。在整个60年代到70年代，人们越来越感觉到这些工业羽流真的非常危险。人们一直在努力弄清关于我们到底应该担心到什么程度的事实。然而这些公司却极其不诚实。甚至连他们在幕后进行的研究，也对公众隐瞒。
So how do you begin to sort of like make sense of the complexity of the thing? How do you paint the picture that you're painting? Yeah, I think that for starters, you do have to acknowledge that there's a whole host of problems or deficits or disaster. that can happen to a person that lead them down that path. It's not just let exposure, but there could be genetic factors. There are now certain genes that may be associated with increased aggression. There's, as you say, violence in the home, domestic abuse, sexual abuse, head trauma. So, yes, there are many, many things that go into this. And I think that what appealed to me was telling the facts that I knew about Asarco, how Asarco behaved to follow their
因此，这些公司的行为最终在我看来，在某种程度上反映了连环杀手的行为，我觉得这很重要，值得我们关注。是的。我的意思是，当我阅读时，最令人着迷的是，这里展示了大量的心理变态，而且不仅限于连环杀手。这太惊人了。这些公司为了保护自己、保护他们的机构，真是不择手段。他们实际上确实进行过讨论，关于他们将不得不支付多少赔偿金，
history of lying about what they were doing, you know, as communities became more and more concerned about the health effects that they were seeing, you know, asthma, you know, all kinds of respiratory problems, pets were dying. You know, they couldn't grow things in their neighborhoods because they're being killed by arsenic. There just was an increasing sense throughout the 60s and into the 70s that these industrial plumes were really dangerous. And people were really struggling to try and get a hold of the facts about how worried should we be. And yet the companies were incredibly dishonest. And even the research that they were doing behind the scenes, they were keeping from the public.
给那些铅中毒的儿童的家庭，他们将因诉讼而不得不支付的赔偿金与他们将获得的利润进行对比。他们根本没有质疑自己的行为，而只是简单地说：“嗯，你知道，如果我们每个孩子花费1100万美元，我们仍然可以盈利。”接下来的节目中，我们将讨论更多关于致命基础设施的话题，以及默瑟岛浮桥是如何契合卡罗琳关于连环杀手的书的。我是与卡罗琳·弗雷泽再次对话的罗曼·马尔斯。卡罗琳，我们已经讨论了Asarco以及它的烟囱如何释放所有这些毒素。
So the behavior of the companies eventually came to me to sort of mirror the behavior of the serial killers in a way that I thought was important and worth paying attention to. Yeah. I mean, that's the thing that's so fascinating when I read it is like there's lots of psychologists. opathy on display, and it's not just serial killers. It's astonishing. It really is the lengths to which these companies would go to protect themselves, protect their institutions. They actually did, you know, have conversations about how much they were going to have to pay
我们讨论了连环杀手，你写到了他们中有多少人在环境毒性较高的社区长大。还有一件事我想谈谈。你的书中有很多反复出现的隐喻和主题。我最喜欢的一个是关于一座桥。它叫默瑟岛浮桥。我没想到一座桥及其设计会在你这本关于连环杀手的书中占据如此重要的地位。但在某种程度上，你把这座桥呈现为一种连环杀手，因为有多少人在开车穿过它时丧生。有趣的是，这是一座非常不寻常的桥。它是一座浮桥。它就像是浮在水面上的浮筒。就像开着车从一个弹跳城堡的地板上开过去一样。这是一种非常奇特的装置。是的，是的，确实如此。我今天早上查了一下世界上有多少座浮桥，大概只有20座左右，其中大部分都在华盛顿州。那你为什么要把这座桥写进书里呢？它对你有什么重要意义？这座桥对我来说成了一种工程失误和工程师傲慢的隐喻，因为他们并不满足于
the families of the kids who were lead poisoned, and they were comparing those payouts that they might have to make as a result of lawsuits to. the amount of profit that they were going to make. They weren't questioning their behavior in any way. They were just simply saying, well, you know, if it costs us $11 million per kid, we can still make a profit. Coming up, we'll talk more about deadly infrastructure and how the Mercer Island Floating Bridge fits into Caroline's book about serial killer. I'm back with Caroline Fraser. So Caroline, we've talked about Asarco and how its smokestacks are releasing all these toxins.
仅仅拥有一座浮桥，他们还在其中引入了一个元素，这个元素一直被称为“鼓包”。所以，是的，你谈到了“鼓包”和另一个特征“可逆车道”，认为这是这座桥两个独特的危险设计元素。在桥中间设计一个“鼓包”的想法是为了让桥的一部分能够开闭，以便让船只通行。但这同时也意味着司机必须以极高的速度通过“鼓包”的这个弯道，
We've talked about serial killers, and you write about how many of them grew up in neighborhoods with higher environmental toxicity. And there's something else I want to talk about. You have many recurring metaphors and themes in your book. my favorite is a bridge. It's called the Mercer Island Floating Bridge. I did not expect a bridge and it's designed to be featured so heavily in your book about serial killers. But in a way, you present the bridge as a kind of serial killer because of how many people died while driving across it. What's also interesting is that it's a very unusual bridge. It's a floating bridge. It's like a pontoon that's on the water. It's like driving over the floor of a bouncy
这引发了许多碰撞事故。而可逆车道原本是为了让交通能够根据灯光系统改变方向。这同样也引发了许多事故。我的意思是，那段驾驶经历实在是令人胆战心惊。因此当时桥上发生了这么多的事故。人们在抱怨，但实际上什么也没做。20多年来什么也没改变，因为这座桥陷入了关于如何应对这些问题的各种诉讼泥潭之中。我非常喜欢关于桥的隐喻，一方面，这座桥代表着一项工程奇迹。我的意思是，在它建造的时候，这座桥是存在的最大浮动结构。
house. It's a very peculiar thing. Yes, yes, it is. I looked up this morning how many floating bridges there were in the world, and there's only like 20, and the majority of them are in Washington State. So why did you include the bridge in your book? Like, what is its significance to you? The bridge became a kind of metaphor for me of engineering mistakes and the hebrus of engineers because they weren't satisfied. just to have a floating bridge, they introduced this element into it, which was always called the bulge. So, right, you talk about the bulge and this other feature, the reversible lane, as these two, like, uniquely dangerous design elements of this bridge. The idea behind having a bulge in the middle of the bridge is to allow, you know, part of the bridge to open and close to make it, you know, to make it possible for boat traffic to go through. But it also meant that drivers had to navigate this curve of the bulge at really high speed.
这是一项规模宏大的工程。而另一方面，桥梁设计中存在着如此多的人为错误，导致了所有的这些死伤，并最终导致了这座桥的毁灭。从某种程度上说，这类似于你详细描述Asarco对其烟囱周围社区造成的破坏不承担责任的方式。是的。在你的书中，你详细描述了死于这座桥手下的受害者，就像你详细描述特德·邦迪的受害者一样。我的意思是，对于这两者，都有一种轻描淡写的态度。人们并没有真正把所有这些死亡事件与某个单一原因联系起来。是的，那种态度，那种耸耸肩的态度，
beats, and it caused a lot of collisions. And then the reversible lane was meant so that the traffic could change directions based on, you know, system of lights. And that also caused a lot of accidents. I mean, it was kind of a terrifying aspect of the whole experience of driving there. And so there's all these accidents on the bridge at this time. And people are complaining, but nothing is really done. Nothing really happens for 20-something years because the bridge, was mired in all this litigation about how to cope with these issues. I love the metaphor of the bridge because on the one hand, the bridge represents this engineering marvel. I mean, at the time it was built, the bridge was the largest floating structure to exist.
对于这些可怕的事故，这对我来说真的很震撼，当我在报纸报道中读到这些时，它激怒了《默瑟岛记者报》的编辑，以至于她开始在报纸头版刊登这些可怕撞车事故的照片，这就是为什么这份报纸在我的家里被禁的原因。所以，我认为这就是将那些事故深深植入我脑海的事情之一。我们无法谈论它们这一事实，反而让它们对我和我而言更加有趣。直到今天，我依然会梦到这座桥，梦到自己身在桥上，通常是步行，并且试图离开它。所以我想谈谈你在书中所详述的各种结局。
It was this massive undertaking. And on the other hand, there was so much human error in the design of the bridge that led to all these fatalities and also to the bridge's eventual destruction. I mean, it's similar in a way to how you detail Asarko's lack of accountability for the damage they caused to the neighborhoods surrounding the smokestacks. Yeah. And in your book, you detail the victims of who died at the hands of the bridge, much like you, you know, you do the victims of Ted Bundy. I mean, for both of them, there's a kind of like kind of dismissiveness. Like people weren't really connecting all these deaths to anyone cause. Yeah, that attitude, the sort of, you know, shrugging of the shoulders up.
太平洋西北地区Asarco烟囱的终结，桥梁的终结，以及太平洋西北地区连环杀手活动高峰期的终结。让我们从桥开始吧。它是怎么没的？他们在80年代中期的某个时候最终拆除了那个“鼓包”。然后，西雅图迎来了一场特大暴雨（意料之中），那是89年或90年的感恩节前后，暴雨来临时，桥体内灌满了水，然后就沉没了。好吧，那塔科马附近的Asarco工厂呢？最后怎么样了？塔科马的Asarco冶炼厂在社区中引发了越来越多的争议，
about these terrible accidents, it was really striking to me, you know, to read about this in the newspaper accounts and it inflamed the editor of the Mercer Island reporter such that she began featuring photographs of these terrible crashes on the cover of the newspaper, which is why the newspaper got banned in my house. So that, I think, is one of the things that implanted those accidents in my mind. The fact that we couldn't talk about them made them all the more interesting to me. To this day, I still have dreams about the bridge, you know, of being on it, often on foot, and trying to get off of it. So I want to talk about the various endings that you detail in the book.
贯穿整个70年代。与此同时，随着环境保护局（EPA）的成立和《清洁空气法》的通过，冶炼厂的经济形势发生了根本性的变化，合法运营一家冶炼厂变得几乎不可能。因此，该公司不得不不断申请变更许可，由于Asarco在塔科马经济中的重要经济地位，这些申请不可避免地得到了批准。但到了80年代，他们将无法再像过去那样做生意了，
the end of the Asarko smokestack in the Pacific Northwest, the end of the bridge, and the end of peak serial killer activity in the Pacific Northwest. So let's start with the bridge. How did it end up going away? They finally removed the bulge in, I'm thinking it was the mid-80s at some point. Then they had a major rainstorm, surprise, surprise in Seattle, in Thanksgiving of, I think it's 89 or 90, and when there was the storm, it filled up with water and sank. Okay, so what about the asarco plant near Tacoma? What ended up happening with that? The Asarco smelter in Tacoma was becoming more and more controversial in the community
他们将无法再获得盈利。因此，Asarco于1986年关闭了该工厂，并在同一时间开始关闭他们在西部蒙大拿州和犹他州的所有其他设施，以至于现在，
throughout the 70s. At the same time that the economic situation was changing radically for smelters because of the creation of the EPA, the passage of the Clean Air Act, it was becoming almost impossible to operate a smelter legally. And so the company kept having to go and apply for variances, which they were inevitably granted because of the economic importance of Asarko in the Tacoma economy. But by the 80s, they were not going to be able to do business the way they had been doing it. they weren't going to be able to make a profit. And so Asarko closes that plant in 1986 and at the same time begins closing all their other facilities in the West in Montana and Utah, such that there
我相信美国境内只剩下三家原生冶炼厂仍在运营。因此，Asarco开始面临各种诉讼。他们面临着破产。与此同时发生的另一件大事，是环保局最终对含铅汽油表明了立场。含铅汽油开始在全国范围内缓慢逐步淘汰。这绘制出了一张非常有趣的图表：在70年代和80年代，暴力犯罪激增，连环杀手数量激增。然后随着关闭冶炼厂和淘汰含铅汽油的运动在90年代中期到末期完成，你开始看到美国的暴力犯罪像跳崖一样断崖式下跌，
are now, I believe, only three primary smelters still operating in the United States. So Asarco starts facing all these lawsuits. They're looking at bankruptcy. And another major thing that happens around the same time, is that the EPA finally takes a position on leaded gasoline. And leaded gas starts to slowly phase out across the country. It's a very interesting graph that this creates because there's a rise in violent crime, a rise in the number of serial killers throughout the 70s and 80s. And then with the completion of this movement to close smelters and remove leaded gas by the mid to late 90s, you start to see violent crime drop off a cliff in the United States
世界其他发达经济体也是如此。你觉得自己破解了连环杀手的密码吗？我不知道自己是否发现了连环杀手的“大一统理论”，但我确实认为那是历史上的一个时期，由于某种原因，这类活动变得非常普遍，我真的渴望找到某种方式来解释它。不管这是不是真的，我们拭目以待。但对我来说，它构成了一个迷人却又悲惨的故事，讲述了一个幸运的是似乎已经结束的时代。是的。我的意思是，如果我们不能对连环杀手得出任何明确的、可证明的结论，我很好奇，你是否得出某种结论？我的意思是，这本书是你一生中似乎一直盘旋的许多未解之谜的高潮。
and other developed economies around the world. Do you feel like you've cracked the code on serial killers? I don't know that I have discovered the unified field theory of serial killers, but I do think that it was a time in history when this kind of activity became endemic. for some reason, and I really yearned for some way to explain it. Whether it's true or not, we'll see. But to me, it made for a fascinating, if tragic story of an era that is fortunately, seems to be over. Yeah. I mean, if we can't come to any definitive, provable conclusion about serial killers, I'm curious, if you've arrived at some kind of conclusion. I mean, this book is a culmination of a lot of open questions
你觉得心中某种程度上算是有了一个了结吗？哇，这倒是我以前没怎么想过的事情。我想在某种程度上，是的，想要了解更多关于连环杀手的冲动，我觉得已经不在了。我想我已经花够多时间跟连环杀手相处了。好吧，这本书我真的很喜欢。谢谢你来到节目中。
that you seem to have had throughout your entire life. Do you feel like there's some kind of closure there? Wow, that's not something I'd really thought about before. I think in some ways, yes, the urge to know more about serial killers, I think it's not there anymore. I think I've spent enough time with the serial killers. Well, I really enjoyed the book so much. Thanks for coming on the show.
谢谢。和你的交谈非常愉快。“99%隐形”本周由拉沙·马顿制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。我们的执行制片人是凯茜·2。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。库尔特·科尔斯特是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·鲁贝伊、杰森·德莱昂、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·莱、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。
Thank you. It's been great talking to you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lasha Madon, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Our executive producer is Kathy 2. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. Kurt Colestate is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Christopher Rubei, Jason DeLeon, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars.
“99%隐形”的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是天狼星XM播客家族的一部分，总部现在设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在蓝天（BlueSky）以及你自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。
The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In Beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as your own Discord server. there's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里有一个链接，以及99PI过去每一集的链接，网址是99PI.org。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。